[Music]
in pyramid of jizz news Shh that's a lot
of comic that's something guys would try
to attempt I don't know a pyramid a flat
now it's like a pancake
I mean you guys'll mold it yeah or we
could build the Pyramid in jizz all over
it and then cover it evenly
yeah like lays like Krispy Kreme things
I create a mold and then I'd have a
funnel called a [ __ ] funnel and I'll bust
in it like a piggy bank and as it dries
up it will mold into the size of a
pyramid a basis pyramid point proven
proof points dew point proof point
indeed submitted by Keo loves JK news
hey what up he'll Egyptian officials are
investigating a photograph of a man
having sex on top of the Great Pyramid
what how does he do how did he get up
there oh you want to investigate it
though because so initially they thought
that this was faked like photoshopped
I'll show you the photo in question
that's kind of dope you got somebody to
go up there to [ __ ] with what I picture
doggystyle exactly
I picked a doggystyle - yeah yeah this
is a Polish photographer he should have
got a carpet or something yeah magic
carpet they're gonna get up and she got
nothing but stand on the back of her bar
his knees are for sure dirty now it does
look kind of Photoshop though but he
claims that it's real and there is could
be real some of the pictures I take out
a real look Photoshop me to those of us
working out people think that I
photoshop my head in there special
working out that's what you know but it
does look for one that's funny yeah so
then he also uploaded this video which
proves that see I did do it you want to
you want to make it know so they have
clothes on well why is it blurred he's
luring up the girl's identity
we got a hooker in Egypt and then no and
that they were posing that they were
having sex that they weren't really
having sex that's weird that's so
awkward
yeah like an artistic thing the music
choice
pretty dope picture though
[Music]
straightening support she has nice
titties from that little side boob at
least they really blurt it unlike the
Chinese new sources where it's just
blurring just like the eyes but dr. tofu
is they blurred like half the body they
don't even try do they blow out the
pupil yeah that's about him that's
really beautiful
I said he was polish she's Danish my bed
anyway his name is Andreas and it turned
from a hot dog to a bread to me I love
cheese not ignorant we all know Costco
hotdogs are no it's a cheese danish okay
I heard they don't have the polish dogs
anymore no hospital no they don't or
they just like cleverly renamed for like
political correctness just a Danish hot
dog no bomb anyway so in his description
he wrote in late November 2018 a friend
and I climbed the Great Pyramid of Giza
aka Pyramid of Khufu pyramid of two both
samples
anyway okay anyone you miss yeah
essential Sam
he was like fearing to be spotted by the
many guards I did not film the several
hours of sneaking around at the Giza
Plateau which led up to the climb so
they're saying it's illegal to climb
yeah that's why I'm surprised how he got
up there cuz there's other like parkour
people and those what you know those
guys with the squirrel suits that jump
off things or whatever like there's all
these girls
there's yeah there's these people that
want to illegally get up there and then
there's security that that catches them
yeah and so that's why now the Egyptian
authorities are looking into this
because because it's illegal they want
to prosecute these people how they gonna
get him extradited like did they already
go back to their mother country I think
you just he just [ __ ] shot himself in
the foot because he can never go back I
don't think he cares anymore though he's
uptown yeah he can never go back but
like that's never going down like that
never not happened he got what he wanted
I don't think he gives a [ __ ] about
going back and how gangsters Egypt are
they so gangster where
those guys mysteriously died in a car
accident three years later because
there's full there's like governments
that are like that too
we're not like oh no they just had a new
government so you know that whole Arab
Spring thing so now it's like four or
five year period yeah four or five and
it's probably at Disneyland or something
I don't know how crazy that new
government is well yeah they're saying
that a lot of people are mega offended
because you know they're mega it's like
one of the what how many wonders in the
world seven one of the seven wonders of
the world and then there but it was
interesting though because I found out
through this article that the scaling
the pyramids were banned just as early
as like the 80s like just recently they
banned that how come I always thought
that you could just get up there go oh
so there's already like grandparents in
this light sounds like yeah I'm thinking
about the mud there's my in their beds
right yeah you could you can climb those
oh right yeah yeah why did the one in
Mexico I don't know what the other one
that's a Mayan one right so people can
[ __ ] on those ones if you want there's a
lot of people that give the pyramids and
then they they do graffiti is common
they're like you know like I was here
mark their little thing I would think
you would have be able to do the minor
one because people got their hearts
ripped out on top of that [ __ ] right
back in the day yeah so I thought that'd
be a little a lot weird actually
ignorant but like in like the Egyptian
culture and stuff like that what are
their views on like sex yeah but then
the pyramids isn't like a Muslim
creation like this older than that yeah
well that's what I'm saying specifically
like the that would they have like the
hieroglyphics of them having sex object
that's what I thought I thought there
was like hieroglyphs before you meet the
ancient I'm talking like a pyramid okay
like where they pens on who you ask like
what did they offend they offend like
Egypt as a whole or like the ancient
like
like the culture or the nation he's a
wolf head coming down and he's like yo
can't be I think it's the nation of
Egypt like this is it's like hey y'all
[ __ ] on top on the Lincoln Memorial
you're not not even Egyptian to you guys
just came over here and just did some
cuz he thought it was cool you know what
the best Egyptian movie is Scorpion King
that's my favorite [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
mommy what about the mummy the original
original there's the mummy but Scorpion
King has the rock I just go I just
remember there was the [ __ ]
half-naked asian girl that I really
liked that not Indiana Jones yeah you
know it's crazy about the pyramids right
so a lot of people or think are also
theorizing that it's a power plant back
in the day oh yeah for sure
I loved watching the the actual pyramids
yeah in terms of how like the collected
energy and suckers they're like it
doesn't make sense that it's a tomb like
I really want to tell you say it well
when I went to Mexico and don't be
welcome and then we climb up to the top
of the pyramid everyone gathered at the
center of the pyramid they were all
putting their hands in the center and
they were saying like you could get
energy from it all
I got mad at my dad for some stupid
reason I was just like no I'm not I was
like that's anger you got like bad years
although I thought you were like that
was like the scible years ago or
something no okay let me sell the damn
child the pyramids are not a tomb it's a
power yeah because they're like all
tombs Egyptian tombs there's are there's
like a bunch of treasure for the for the
people that there's coffins yeah and
then this one there's nothing yeah
there's no actual like there's no - yeah
they have one thing that's kind of a
tomb is just a big box that they call
like this
I forgot that yeah but it's it's not
even it's not even there's nothing in
there yeah it just looks like it just
looks like a shape of a rectangle that's
it there's nothing in there so when they
went in there there they didn't find
anything there's no art it's not richly
decorated but they're talking about how
like the outside surface or shell of the
pyramid used to be like either like gold
or whatever it was that would actually
be a conductor or reflector of energy
and then there was water in that whole
area - yeah well it was the whole area
had water and they were saying that if
it went through like a like a through
the pyramid like there's one in the RET
like under the pyramid
oh kinda like what we have now we're
like a large great energy
yeah we're some smart guy
used as like a window that's one of the
theories I'm just saying I don't know
the [ __ ] mechanics so you're not just
saying that they had electricity back
why sure sure was a lot back then and it
was that it just went off-road a lot of
conspiracy they do people even know how
they were constructed because like each
one of those things are going to jillion
tons right like each what do you say
that the the brick that they were being
out of it was like from way far away
where it was I can possible to bring it
Oh cuz aliens did it dude do you really
believe that yeah I do I wish I could
see if alien I'm kind of like super down
to believe it I don't know if like in my
heart of hearts I truly believe it but I
also truly don't understand why we
haven't figured it out therefore it must
be beyond us you didn't Hawking's
uh wasn't he like don't make any contact
with like we should never do that like
he was always going against like we
should not make any contact or try to
make any contact with like easy that's a
treasure oh you mean like proactively by
like way of science satellite he's like
let's just leave it alone like he knew
some [ __ ] he was trying to warn us oh
we're still trying to watch we could
like excavate the [ __ ] pyramid and
then we find out that we used to have
like superpowers some [ __ ] cuz I was
searched my whole life to get some type
of super power we used to have dog heads
what it's already in the hieroglyphs we
had dog heads and animal heads like the
bird how would you see yeah yeah it's
the art like like the different gods
like sex yeah yeah and there's lions
with human heads yeah or the dreams of
like the wings is I would love to find
the skeletal remains of a person who has
a dog head in human thought that she's
my whole life I was searched to get
superpowers
cuz it's real it exists so you found a
fossil of a dog head human body and you
would go look for superpowers because
that just shows there's there's truth
with all the other mythical stories
would you give up your face and have a
dog face just to get your powers
depending on what the superpower is I
hope he says yes like if I get the dog
face and the superpower is that I could
just change time then of course what's
the lowest level superpower you're down
for for a dog face
I can grow my nails as long as possible
I wonder if you get a Dogface you start
doing dog things like licking your own
dick a guy probably but that's the first
thing you do why don't you get a dog
face too
you don't become you anymore you become
the dog because its brain is on your
body now yeah is it a dog what the human
body now okay that's like satanic week
says the super long nails for notaries
yeah but I'm saying if I could you guys
will all be amazing they're all so
upright though they do walk around the
dog net people that's true oh this I've
never seen them a picture I don't want
that satanic right and that's like
satanic stuff like where Satan says I
can give you all the money in the world
but or a genie the genie - yeah yeah
don't don't make wishes just work for it
you have a negative you know thing - oh
yeah it's always attached what it is you
want a good superpower but nothing that
follows yeah no strings attached
so like the superpower is that there's
no catch exactly oh I don't think that
exists because all the superheroes
there's a there's something there's
something that they hate about the cape
of the costs that are all true story
that's life okay
yeah I like but make it minor right like
make it make the inconvenience like like
I was I want to be super mad but I just
want to be allergic to peaches ah more
peaches on the earth and kryptonite yeah
I'm at a slight allergy night peanut
allergy
Oh how do I get peaches just sniffing my
eyes yeah
[Music]